Make the most of this cuteness and become a person who is loved by everyone It's
not that I put up with it for everyone's sake, but that's what
everyone
wants me for I'm doing my best, so I won't just be a good girl
Mr.
Shiraki is different,
so Mr. Mamiya is also a little
better than everyone else.  Because I had a
terrible time being taken apart.To tell the
truth, I didn't want to tell anyone anymore.It's
only Mamiya-san who knows.  You
look alike, don't you?
That dismembered guy and Mr. Mamiya are similar to me. On the
contrary, he says everything he thinks.  I
don't hate Shiraki-san, I want you to do
that I've made friends with you, so please let me
rest on the outside.
Things
[music]
Cuteness is amazing
That's how we started